That's all right.
Did you see Roy McDonald ask him?
Ben Asks you to sign with del Toro and Ben asked her wants to do it too.
Um,
I then asked her and still owes fights with one fc though.
So they would have to do some sort of a [inaudible] contract with them.
Yeah,
he owes two fights.
He owes two fights.
One FC,
I know you're listing do us all a solid,
do all the hardcores Assad them out,
man.
So you're never going to set them out.
What they would do is they would cope.
I'm out and it's possible you now,
if you want to fight in the UFC,
it's possible.
Oh hell.
Co-Promote with one fc you would have to,
it would have to be favorable conditions with the UFC where like they just,
you know,
you can make some sort of a deal with one of seeking stream it or some shit.
Then they would have to be something or they give them a piece of the revenue,
but it would have to be a very small,
the odds are already against and the sign with the assignment,
you go all right.
Now you got to make this deal with one FC and Dana [inaudible] kick rocks.
Well he should do is he should get out of that contract.
That's what he should just smoke two news real fast.
Just smash two dudes.
Just gimme two cans,
but he's the can crusher over there.
Rich Franklin's the guy who does the hell did he Kinko's?
Matt Hume is to Matt Hume's a partner when I was fellow.
What's up?
Let's get this one of the greatest fights all the time.
Roll in my man.
Well who would you have in fight Woodley?
I he's friends with with their trading partners.
I'd have them fight GSP first and they'll hand fight.
Could Be,
do you think GSP would take that fight?
But nobody knows who asked her name is outside of the hardcore fans.
He said he would could be convene three months ago.
70 yeah.
I don't know.
[inaudible] started 70 oh shit.
That is the fight I want to see.
It could be and no ass grin.
Oh,
me too.
Khabib is what I would want to set my number one five d because good luck taking
GSP down.
Just good luck and good luck standing with them too.
You know the,
the standup,
there's a big gap between Ben Asker and stand up at GSP,
so this isn't a big gap between Ben astrons grappling.
Just scrapping.
Sure.
Cap.
It's true.
It's amazing.
Fight when there's a big gap between what Ben Grins is grappling and GSPS
grappling.
Really big gap.
There's a big gap.
Shit.
Olympian.
Legitimate GSP.
Yeah.
GSP and aspirin.
Big Gap.
Yup.
If they wrestled,
that's great.
Okay.
Do you think y'all good Woodley [inaudible] Woodley GSP has more takedowns in
UFC history.
You're right.
I never write a guide at the level of aspirin when it comes to wrestling.
He's the best guy.
He's a black belt in Jiu Jitsu.
No,
you're right.
If it gets to the ground,
the best,
the best guy he fought as far as wrestling credentials,
who probably Josh Koscheck my,
yeah.
My thought would be that GSP would never let,
oh,
he's doubled up too.